[Music]
last week ABC announced that Michael
Strahan the co-host of live with Kelly
and Michael would be leaving the show to
go to Good Morning America yeah
but here's the thing ABC didn't tell
Kelly Ripa that Strahan was leaving
until 30 minutes before they made it
public so yeah she was understandably
better she was understandably she was
understandably furious and I have to say
I am with Kelly Ripa on this one if you
get a better job the classy thing to do
is to tell the person you work with
first that's how it's done okay I mean
Kelly might have been happy for Strahan
but to leave your partner in the dark
until the last minute that's just plain
wrong you don't do it
now I get it a big burly
ex-jock who's charming and funny
off-the-cuff is bound to get offers from
other shows I know it happens I mean a
guy like that can write his own ticket
in this business but for God's sakes
tell your partner first
don't blindside your partner and make
things a thousand times more awkward
it's an on-air relationship it's a
sacred thing Andy the cameras been
cutting to you a lot is there something
you want to tell me no I mean now get
just go put it in the car
seriously the view you're living me for
the view
yes they're looking for a feminine take
on today's story I've never seen a sign
on a little rack telling you where it's
going this is part of that you know
there's always a sign on luggage it says
right it's going that's making sketches
that's like a Three Stooges comedy I
have like that's a classic only the best
for my team
[Applause]
you